and the goal for this tournament is to
play a lot oh it's John Bartholomew
wait is John streaming too
Finns oh no my rating
am I gonna play Oh John's streaming too
oh that's apparently we've only we've
all played John first round on uh lee
Chess at least do I speed run prepare
his candy oh and his stream title says
uh super aggressive Blitz
he's probably gonna play the London
against me I'll probably just wing it
maybe I'll play the B4 gambits and
literally wing it
one of the OG streamers
one of my role models when it comes to
eight chess and YouTube and twitch five
four three two one okay
uh we gotta play E4
moving ed5
is John gonna play us oh he plays
Sicilian
okay
um what what variations does he play
here
let's play C4
this used to be my pet line
uh I'm playing a con
I'm trying to be tricky with the move
order
okay he's gonna play a hedgehog
ah he made a video on the Hedgehog a
while ago
I have to play F3
and then comes to D7
I'll start with Queen D2 because there's
cases where the afro comes the C1
uh Eric D1 though
maybe Rook C1
yeah Rooks on C1 and D1 seem pretty
solid
coin F2
this is all pretty standard whoa It's a
thousand bits
thanks so much
I don't have so much time to look at
chat though because I'm trying to focus
John is probably Ultra focused right now
G4 I know is a idea
um
might be three
before
I'll play G4 it defends the pawn in the
event of these ideas
it's a little bit loosening to the king
side
also I just spent a lot of time on that
move
yeah he's gonna try and use the clock as
a weapon
uh don't hurt me
I don't think sacking on G4 works
if necessary H3 can come
I feel like H3 F4
Bishop G2
and gradually gain space
have to claim my territory
uh maybe F4 first
nah Let's Play Bishop G2 first
just preparing to defend E4
I mean H4 G5 is an idea I can maneuver
the Knight to G3
can I not draw an arrow
my arrow settings reset to the default
I think I'll play this
because it unleashes the battery
prepares this
I do eventually want to expand
now if I play F4
Knight G6
so Knight G3 I also have G5
there's E5 as well
E5 take take E5 looks fascinating
also looks really risky
so the calculation is takes takes Bishop
moves back I take on G7
as the giving away light Square Vision
also if takes I Trot the bishop
won't hurt me
of this move
I also have Knight G3
this move is terrifying
voila oh F5 doesn't work
I can take though
and just block the battery
Bishop D4 defending this Pawn's a little
bit loose
my king should not be on H2 anymore
I have 48 seconds
I think I just play King G1
B4 F5
not the 95
I have no idea what's going on
I play Rook F1 because I want to go for
this line Rook F1 defends against Knight
F3 Forks
I have 25 seconds
I'm threatening some eventual mate
always play off six
so King H7 out of this move
Bishop f8
it's such a passive move
and see what to do though
that's a slow time scramble
oh good move
don't hurt me
don't
oh I got dirty there good game John
oh what a crazy game
I I was losing at the end
it was a little bit too slow a little
bit too weak what a crazy game though
it seemed like the attack was almost
crashing through
but then I didn't find a great Square
for my knight maybe I should have played
Knight A4
um
wow that was a fun game
I tried to play aggressively
thank you poisoned Von
thank you oolong oh gifting to Nemo
what's up Nemo sorry I missed the raid I
was so focused on trying to
now lose to John
yeah shout out to Nemo also thank you to
the learner zero who cheered a thousand
bits before the raid
okay what is this username
uh all right stop for Gambit time
I'm berserking
for those new here and not familiar with
what it means to berserk
when I cut my time in half
and uh if I win the game I get an extra
point for the tournament
I think this is okay
this is super risky though
so I'm subjecting myself to discoveries
but the idea is if Knight moves anywhere
I take the bishop
and now I just diffuse a diagonal
ooh
you can take here
wait a minute
yeah that's not so simple
[Music]
what have I done
take take
but actually what have I done
and try this
I have 47 seconds left
I'm throwing a funny Maiden 2 which
would never happen
okay let's just run to the corner D6
checks shouldn't be too painful
I am down two pawns though
oh no my failed Gambit
please hang your queen
okay
so I've gamuted two pawns and most of my
time
but in compensation I have the night
pair
if only those were duck chess am I
winning now takes and rookie one and
then back ring checkmate
how does
how does white defend I guess Queen uh
Queen z7
take
I'm not winning
I think I'm just losing
that was a good move
okay 20 seconds
up the tempo here
the hope is this move and then I made
into
ah okay a lot of Bishop F7 there
please play visit T2 yes okay now I have
hope I also have 11 seconds
where's my funny mate
putting this
[Music]
foreign
that was the worst move
doll
I want the side of the Stanley trap too
oh okay there goes my reading
so close yet so far
ah
had my chances there
not the best start to a tournament
opponent played well though I got
confused in the opening
they gambited against my staff right and
then
um okay no more berserking
what are my chances of coming back this
tournament
let's play a two nights attack
I'm gonna try and um be a little bit
more controlled but still aggressive
this is one of my favorite lines against
the Carroll Khan
that's a nice peace Harmony
um play I think I'll just Castle
one middle game plan is to eventually
play Pawn F4
um
yeah it looks like this almost works but
okay let's play nine to five first
A4 preventing Pawn B5
yeah this is kind of the dream position
from the opening
Bishop d5's coming
and now yeah the issue for black there's
a lot of tactical targets
I think I have you even have Knight G7
here
idea of being Knight H5 is coming
and then that would be um a fork but
also a pin
so
pretty delicious pork
we might see King G6
and then Bishop takes F6
so hitting the queen
so the queen defends the Knight defends
the bishop attacks the queen
and F5
and just this move
and dominant Bishops
the question remains though how do I
Checkmate the king
okay let's just take a free rook
maybe someday this Rook can get involved
oh no my Pawn
opponent sees through my trickery
but I'm up a whole Rook here
uh let's play this
I'm going after the pinned Bishop I
could have started at this
okay this is a nice game to recover from
what happened in the past
thank you D Lobster
also thank you Anonymous gifting too
from earlier I think you pie hole
multimore Duke Duke poisonak poison Pawn
yeah I appreciate people supporting and
creating hype
okay my goal is to break into the top
hundred
also thank you Curly MO
yeah if you're just joining this is an
hourly super Blitz Arena
um
I told myself I wasn't gonna berserk but
too late muscle memory took over
we might have a Stonewall coming up
yeah against the Stonewall I like to
play the setup
a very harmonious setup
A4 I've never seen before
[Music]
um yeah the idea of the setup is to
essentially trade light Square Bishops
um let's start with Queen B6
eventually I want to play Knight E4
I Rook C8 first
okay now let's take a 94
although I have to watch out for this
Fork
what have I done
okay playing a bit more positionally
here
so now I got confused
oops wait did I have B6 pre-moves
I may have had B6 pre-move that whole
time
sure though
okay how to do this takes and just F6
so if takes I take back and defend
because Queen and pawn create the
battery
and this is kind of the dream from a
Stonewall
to get a situation like this where I
have
a slightly better Bishop
okay hitting B2
and the question is how do I make
progress
to play this move first
let's get a little bit unsettling
oops
wait if takes I have to take this way
okay I think White had some chances
there
each Pawn is going to roll
and King's still safe
maybe the queen can crawl in
okay now the king side's completely
closed down
and the focus of play will shift so the
queen side
Bishop belongs on D6
don't hurt me just allow C4
I think I allowed C4 but opponent just
gifted me everything
okay now I have to win with 21 seconds
winning more material
okay not to clean this game
I'll take it though
welcome to all the first time chatters
okay top 40. so I broke into that half
hundred
I passed John John's still playing
oh John's is like winning games a little
bit more slowly
I'm not sure my odds of winning this
tournament and I am with
a lot of points
okay we have reverse London
I'll try and play this aggressively
the bishop here
aggressive way to play this is C5 and
then Knight C6
and even sometimes casting Queen sign
Knight H4 I'm happy to see
because I really don't mind the half
open each file
now it's hard for a way to attack on the
queen side
I have D5
D5 is maybe Justified
oh
Bishop F4
so it's now more of a closed but no need
structure
type position
[Music]
I could try and pry things open with F5
always have to be alert of this move
that move I've probably taken with a
pawn
um
okay I'm not sure what White's doing so
I'm gonna wait and just see what White's
plan is
F5
take
F5 is interesting
it's a weird Pawn break
my Bishop's not so happy about it but
I am applying pressure
and after this trade I have the H file
this diagonal is nice battery's nice
okay now I can take
there's this positional sack
yeah I think this was called for I don't
know though
it's it's a positional sacrifice I'm
sacrificing the pawn for a square
I just want the D4 Square for the Knight
and maybe like the square for the bishop
or the other Knight can come in
put the bishop here first
hitting the Rook trying to unleash the D
file
pressuring the pawn
so I'm down the pawn here but I I think
I have full compensation
wow white just resigns
is back even better Queen C2
yeah Black's doing quite well it
shouldn't be like immediately losing
though
but
I guess the fact that I sacked upon
maybe terrified the opponent
okay we'll try and get more gambits in
um berserking E4
okay scandi time
Queen A5 B4
I'm just winging it
so this was a Gambit declined but I'm
still trying to play hyper aggressively
also have to complete development
got the pieces in position to attack
and Bishop D6 is coming
if I take take on C6 first maybe no
there's a funny line where I sat my
queen and then make a new one
I like this move because C4 is now
enabled
yeah F5 is a one move threat but it
creates a very long term weakness
Dole I got forked
uh let's play this and
confuse everyone
this is a counter Fork
I might end up sacking The Rook
I might end up sacking my queen as well
I still have this idea
so Queen D6 I take and then take and hit
the queen again
Queen D7 is probably a good move
and if I take
take their
all right let's have some fun
oh no my Rook
actually not sure if this is working
it looks like fun though now Bishop H5
is a monster threat
and knight's just chilling
96 is probably coming next regardless
where the king moves
yeah this is a double check King g8's
only legal move
and then Queen G7 checkmates
[Music]
okay that was a fun game
got some nice hacks in that game
so 14 tournament points
top 10. after a rocky start
uh no berserking 32 minutes left
many more games to play
maybe stop for Gambit time
yeah this is like one of the most basic
traps in the Stafford
and D3 Knight C3 is not a great
combination of the moods
now each five
so if I take maybe just Bishop E6
try and use the Bishops as
just fuel for my attack against the
white king
all right so Queen A5 is met with A3
I could take on G2 it's a free Pawn
not scared of Rook G1
it's hard for white to find a move here
actually
and my next move is probably costling
maybe push H Pawn
White's very stuck
yeah apologies I can't interact too much
with chat
but after the tournament I can chat
answer questions
Etc
do I want to trade Queens probably not
generally
a queen trade favor is a side whose King
is less vulnerable
here White's King is more vulnerable
there's more attacking potential for
black
Queen A5 and already there's big issues
threatening to take him in the pawn but
also taken when this Pawn
probably throw in F6
although yeah maybe I shouldn't have
gone for this
if like Queen side Castle
[Music]
um
I'm still up a pawn even after Queen G7
maybe what I'll do there's a funny line
Queen G7
check here check
oh King D2 first
never mind
okay so rookie one's the threat so let's
play this
yeah now I want to play Queen F2
up a lot of time here
um G6 is solid Queen F2 is
actually looking very nice
Queen defends the pawn from a distance
if Rook here then the rook's overworked
and I take
uh Queen F4
Aegis F6
my White's very tied down
you might plan this to play this and
this
probably could have played this right
away
yeah there's this pin this pin
oh that's check
uh thankfully I have this move
okay
okay Seventh Place
18 tournament points
what happened to John
oh no my John John just won all his
games and
maybe quietly paused
retire on top
oh John rated
when did John read
oh John rated a minute ago I didn't even
see
thanks John for the rain I appreciate
that I have alerts muted okay let's play
E4 if you're just joining I'm trying to
recover from
the painful loss against John trying to
win the tournament
still have some fighting back to do
I'll play A3
uh Bishop E3
some sort of like classical Sicilian
variation
you can take
I'm not sure about this though
I'm just kind of improvising here
E5
I really just improvising
Queen takes I probably have to take
at least I got the bishop to D4
so I like my Bishops
reminds me of a French
uh takes
okay let's play very positionally
I'm trying to hammer away at this weak
Pawn
yeah this is no longer a super
aggressive super Blitz
this is superpositional super Blitz
putting most of my pawns on dark squares
now all my pawns are not experienced
complimenting my Bishop
um and then I'll I'll just control the
center
with the major pieces
I think I want to Triple up and
eventually like get in some F5 move
it's not super simple to break through
though
one maybe bishop H3 coming
okay I have four attackers against this
Pawn there's only what two Defenders
now sometimes it's easy to miss this
maneuver so Bishop seems so happy on
D3
one Pawn should be enough to win this
two Pawns
maybe more than enough
I play this move
oh no my queen
I think Quincy it's the best move here
because Rook here I have rookie eight
what to do
I gotta move quickly
it's hard to simplify though
I'm still trying to control the center
I want to play this move
threading this
new checks
I should just trade Queens
okay just enough time
oh dear thank you Platinum gamer
appreciate the prime sub
okay uh
23 points
still a lot of catching up to do
sixth place though
berserking
this is a time where I really have to
start playing more aggressively
because I can't afford a long game
and just eats up too much time left in
the tournament
okay what is this opening
one's going for a hippo
um
and try and bust a hippo G4
G4 is super risky though
wow okay let's take
and get in each five
probably not the most recommended way to
play against the hippo
but now black can't Castle kingside
I'm gonna be quick to Castle queenside
trying to calculate E5 Queen H7
that Bishop's almost trapped
only way to defend is oh there's this
hanging though
wait what's happening
okay King E7 I played this
I'm going to start with the check
so I'm delaying taking because here here
and I'm almost winning the queen but not
quite oh I am winning the queen or am I
I'm winning the king
Chuck
Knight okay
I won the king yeah I think black had to
either give the queen or get me to there
okay uh man leader has 40 points
uh and I'm playing the leader so no
berserking
a serious game
not quite a Gambit yet
okay gambling this Pawn
reverse Queen's Gambit
um yeah Gambit non-acception
I'll still try and play aggressively
I'll try and employ this setup
are we just transposing into the nepo
ding game
some
I'm in the castle Queen side though
maybe
probably
uh
yeah I might as well
and get some G5 action
I play G5 immediately
okay it's getting spicy
in G3 I'd probably suck
almost definitely suck
issue for white the knights tied down to
D4
so I can take on E2 first and then take
on D4 and then Knight and queen are
vulnerable
Forks are in the air
okay this opening worked out pretty well
sometimes G5 can backfire
foreign
's Happening Here
92 and win The Rook
it's also Knight E4
92.
still some compensation for whites but
I'm mobile full Rook
as defends and gives the bishop room to
move back
some ideal Bishop C3
oops
okay I'm still up of he's
got the thing attack the queen
I can take here
Queen A6 is one check
F2 is vulnerable now
actually I'm threatening I was
threatening to take and then Fork
okay King is pretty safe
this is my Center TP
F2 is hard to defend
okay just restricting any 95 checks
because I want to play this move
there were probably other options like
Rook B8
Queen G3 is a funny idea
um
yeah just too many choices
it's running this now
I think those works
so a lot of catching up to do
I'm assuming I can win this
wow
okay
no time to waste
so I'm still on the streak
eight points are the first
yeah that was a fun opening that last
game like reverse Queen's Gambit okay
berserking this game
playing Tash Tosh
still offering a Stafford
so this is actually transposing
take that take
probably not
E5 Queen E7
let's move
has some weird opening
it's just a smooth
solidifying
Queen C4 I have Queen B4
confusing position though
and D6 takes
um
and just G6 now
F6
I'm just castling
so if this I just play Queen E6
wow
it takes I probably take with Queen
some of a pawn
I want to attack
like Bishop E6 Knight B4
I was imagining some Knight C3 ideas
okay this a pawn looks like a Target uh
[Music]
just play this
I don't mind the trade
wow
White's playing aggressively too
visually Southern King h8
I'm hitting the queen and if takes takes
I win the knights
otherwise I can take and
how to attack like Bishop A2 Queen C5
or queen C5 also
aligns on the fifth rank
I think I'm just winning material here
because I'll remove the bishop and then
do I want to start with
let's start with this
I have 22 seconds I forgot I berserked
okay
where's my meat
I think this
hmm
very least I should win on time
the very most I should be meeting
B2 is hard to defend
I can't wait somehow defending
I had Queen D2
okay oh that's a funny game so I'm in
second place
almost caught up to the leader
and then keep things aggressive
another Carol Khan
another two nights attack
yeah this line uh each three first
Bishop E2
this is some Theory
I forget my theory though
I think it's this eventually D4
I'm remembering a game between mvl and
Eno agras
and VL pushed the pawn to A5
slightly different position though it's
in that game the knights were traded
I guess I could take if I want
oh
okay hitting the queen
okay this is a good structure now
I think I'm winning a pawn too
Knight takes
foreign
[Music]
maybe I am winning upon
this is still a threat
and Bishops control so many squares
okay maybe I'm not winning upon
I didn't berserk this game
as
okay let's
start with this
but the bishop
okay I want to play A6 and take on E7
foreign
okay
got the win first place it's been a long
journey but the journey is not over
uh this person is on my tail
but they're not on the streak
this person's on the streak
playing toshtosh again
uh we'll play a Grand Prix attack how
that
against whatever this is
there there there does this work
gotta try it
I'm not sure if this works though
yeah this is kind of risky to go into
I didn't want to allow cringy to
rook's hanging F5 happens
Queenie 2 probably cons
ists move first
so I'm down a piece
but I have Connect Four
and go after these Pawns
A7 doesn't look like the taste use of
Pawns but it is
possibly free food
oh wow
um
that was a strong move
I'll play this first
and not consuming any free food here
I have 53 seconds left
not what I wanted
I go for the queen trade
I gotta get G4 in
h3g4
that was a good move
oh dear
that's not good
oh good move
I'm down the Rook
it's still a little bit of fight
foreign
six
uh not a good position
check
mates
wow that turned it around quickly
I was down a rook
but miracles do exist
okay my attack was slightly quicker that
game
this might be my final game
uh what is this
uh C6
I don't know Theory here I feel like
this is a bad ponziani
I have this move
that's probably not a good move though
you play this
okay we're getting something weird
I think I can live with this
sure what's happening though
there
takes I take
and there's takes I play this and skewer
and my structure is not desirable but I
have the bishop hair
oh that was a good move
Bishop G4
trying to be aggressive
a nice shish kebab
I'm not sure what my plan is though like
what's my threat
take
and Bishop E7
um
have this move first
oh no my Pawn
[Music]
yeah lights too good of a player to take
upon I would then win the queen
oh this tricky move
I have to take
rookie eight almost works
hmm
I'm not sure what's happening here
actually let's play this and
that Rook D4 though
okay I'll play this
yeah that's a good move
I'm in trouble
I think I have this move
that positionally this is not pleasant
for black
oh no my Pawn again
still these tactics
and it pains me to play such a move
on just a long-term weakness now
down a little bit of time so this game's
not gonna count for the tournaments
but looks like I've secured first
but there's still work to do
play this first
Bishop D4 coming
okay now it's not so bad
Rook can maybe side over
mind
as a great move
wow
that was a really good move
okay no more back rank issues
22 seconds
I'll play this move
how's my night doing
What's Happening Here
so now I'm defending everything
doll my Rook
[Music]
What a Sad finish